depois de um padre não é fácil falar
depois de um padrão mais um padre que a
torna vamos lá
boa noite boa noite ou melhorou e vamos
definir isso de moraes para ver se ajuda
nessa reflexão e vinícius construiu a
sua obra mais ou menos assim aqui jaz o
sol que criou aurora e deu à luz a vida
ea paz entou à tarde o mágico pastor de
mãos luminosas que fecundou as rosas e
as espetáculo aqui jaz o sol o andrógeno
méxico e violento que possuiu a forma de
todas as mulheres e morreu no mar com as
lágrimas do tempo ea cauda o meu dia eu
fiz o cimento da minha poesia a
perspectiva da vida futura escrevi em
carne viva
sua arquitetura não sei bem se é casa z
torre ou 71 templos em deus mas sei que
é grande e claro pertence ao seu tempo
entrai irmãos meus
nesse momento tão bacana e único que o
pedex rdb oferece pra vocês
valeu
efe am/an